once I believe nation it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my sincere hope is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet I started to
believe life series to help us learn a
little bit more about ourselves grow
personally and ideally bring some of
what we learn about ourselves to our
business to have more success so today
we're going to learn how to be
optimistic in life
[Music]
I think the biggest obstacle to success
is a lack of optimism I think the world
like lacks optimism I think you know
everyone's like your energy your energy
I've come to realize it's just optimism
just happy just positive what it is
[Music]
most of us have situations where there
are four all of you listening a place
where you have some unfinished business
because that's the story of my life
stunning okay Ron your story of all our
lives right it's just a human right but
it's it's a place where there's
something that you should have handled
you haven't handled with a person or
situation it stresses you out and so
what we tend to do is focus on other
stuff because we don't want to have to
deal with that because it's stressful
because you know painful and so think of
something that on a 0 to 10 scale where
10 is totally stressed out and zero is
not at all pick something that's
unfinished business in your business or
personal life with something or someone
and it's at least a seven eight nine or
ten just so you can see that this really
works now by the way there are hundreds
of ways to do this I'm just going to
give this one because we do it in two
minutes right so I'm hoping Tim do you
have one by chance I did okay yeah the
[ __ ] okay forgive me Hitomi the content
no one else Tekonsha alright everyone if
you would just for a moment I don't
really use ik in the background which I
need to enhance this normally but let's
just do it to poke your hands on your
heart and physically read deep into your
heart and as you're breathing deep in
your heart feel the strength of your
heart feel the power of your heart
you're the beauty of your heart what are
you proud or grateful that your heart is
guided you to do or to give or to feel
or to enjoy to feel the strength to not
breathe into it field of blood flow the
oxygen
you're grateful for your heart first
think about it even you have to earn
this heart
it was given to you you didn't have to
prove your value or you're worth you
enough to accomplish anything
something loved you enough to give you
the gift of life as long as its heart is
beating you have that gift and you live
to be a hundred thousand times a day
pumps blood through 60,000 miles of
blood vessels you can amend and they go
around the earth twice at the equator
that's what's inside everyone else you
don't have to think about what it gets
me so as your breathing your heart
feeling your powerful heart I want you
to spend a moment we're going to think
of three but just think first of one of
that in your life want to experience one
moment that you could feel so grateful
for if you want to do a magic moment a
sacred moment sexy moment a beautiful
moment a loving moment any moment really
you could feel grateful for if you
wanted to light now and then stepping in
that memory thing like stuff in your
body as if you were there see what you
would have solved it
if you're there I'll share what you hear
after three the way you were breathing
back and you film up with that sense of
strategy for a moment
and he smile until so grateful so
thankful
[Music]
what's the look in your eyes how do you
breathe look in your face when you feel
really really great
just do what I feel awful gotta tube the
reason we use gratitude by the way and
the two motions enough of the most was
anger and fear and you can't be grateful
and angry simultaneously and young stuff
can't beat fear for magic imitators so
don't be gratitude now think of a second
moment you could feel truly great born
again deep in your heart feel what power
just think of any other moment it could
become your childhood or adulthood it
could be last week could be today could
be 10 years ago any moment that you
could just truly feel like that was
grace that was magical that was
beautiful that that's magnificent
something that gives you the feeling of
tremendous gratitude if you really focus
on it breathe it feel it enjoy it fill
up with gratitude and finally think of a
third moment you can feel truly grateful
for stepped in it see it feel it be
there feel the gods what were you so
grateful for what are you beautiful for
[Music]
and then maybe throw one extra one and
think of coincidence you know we all
love when life happens for it not to us
we love coincidences because we didn't
do anything something happened for us
you're going to do one thing and you met
somebody that you developed a
partnership with or became a friend or a
lover or the level of your life or maybe
a business opportunity came from a coin
set that's where an insight came from a
coincidence that's been so valuable in
your life something you're grateful for
what's the coincidence that led to
something you're so grateful for feel
the gratitude you that
[Music]
wasn't coincidence or were you guided
[Music]
now you breathe in your heart you've
been doing this for about two minutes
keep breathing keep feeling a feeling
grateful let's use the state solve the
problem state the easy way to do that is
just keep breathing your heart stay out
of here in your heart you can think of
that situation that's unfinished
business that stress throughout them
keep reading this beautiful state and
ask yourself this question ask yourself
all I need to focus on in that situation
all I need to focus on all you need to
remember is what your heart knows all I
need to focus on all need to remember
all I need to do in that situation
that's what your heart knows the answer
only to focus on calling it to remember
calling to do is and then your heart how
I know the answer I've done this a
million times
not every one of you but the normal rule
might have speeds they raise your hand
if you've got that answer ninety-eight
ninety-nine to the people usually doing
with this simple technique optimism can
be stoked up like a fire you know you've
got a campfire and it's kind of dying
down and then you can blow air on it you
can put some more kindling on it and
then it'll spark up and flare up well
that's what you can do with your
optimism so right now maybe you're just
feeling kind of at a at a at a baseline
level where you're not too pessimistic
about your future you're not too excited
either so what I recommend you do is you
do the following exercise I want you
take your journal piece of paper
something where you can write and I want
you to write out and lift 30 things that
you're most excited about in the next
year that you're going to do 30 things
that you're super super excited about
maybe said vacation you want to take
maybe it's that relationship that you
hope to get into maybe set promotion at
work you know you're going to get maybe
it's having all your credit card debts
eliminated maybe it's starting that new
business of yours or starting that dream
project or losing some weight whatever
it is but start running it down and be
as specific as
well thirty things that you're excited
about achieving in the next year that
really really motivate you try to focus
on the ones that get you excited this is
simple like that this is all this is the
whole exercise sit down actually do this
take twenty minutes or whatever it takes
you to write all this stuff out what and
notice notice how you feel now just how
you feel right now notice how you feel
before you do the exercise and I want
you to notice how you feel after you
finish it if you're like me you're going
to feel so much more optimistic you're
gonna feel energized you can feel happy
I feel alive you're going to feel like
there's something to your life because
your future now is bright and it's right
here before your eyes you've articulated
it you're you've laid it out very
clearly and it's right before you I
recommend you do this exercise more than
once do it right now but also continue
to do throughout your life continue to
do it do it at least once a month do it
even once a week because it's going to
get you connected back to the stuff
that's exciting to you and it's also
going to you know your mind is going to
brainstorm and come up with new stuff to
put on that list and you can be
brainstorming about what you're gonna do
in for the whole year be but also
localize it down and you can you can
shorten the time frame to something like
the next month or even what we're going
to be doing over the next week or even
today even today you can do it just like
what are five things you're going to be
excited about doing today if you do that
exercise in the morning just for five
minutes what are the five things you're
going to be excited about doing today
it'd probably take you just two minutes
to do that you're going to feel even
much more excited about your day and
you're going to be much more optimistic
I was going through some stuff and a
woman said this to me she's like when
you walk through a doorway say an
affirmation and if you think about it
you think about how many doorways you
walk here in a day a bathroom door your
bedroom door a door of a building your
office door in out every time you go in
or out of a door you have to say
something positive about yourself or
something you believe it's insane if you
try it you end up saying like 400 things
or 500 things a day and it's it's pretty
incredible how fast you see the things
that you say inside of you
and that was something I was really
powerful for me I want to talk to you
now about the big difference between
optimists and pessimists in life between
happy excited fulfilled people and
negative tiring depressed people now
everyone wants to be physically healthy
but it's important to want to be
mentally healthy as well the true
measure of mental fitness is how
optimistic you are about yourself and
your life now in order to become truly
optimistic you must learn how to control
your thinking in very specific ways so
that you feel terrific about yourself
and your situation most of the time no
matter what happens there are three
basic differences in the reactions of
optimists and pessimists the first
difference is that the optimist sees a
setback as temporary while the pessimist
sees it as permanent the optimist sees
an unfortunate event such as an order
that falls through or sales call that
fails as a temporary event something
that is limited in time and that has no
real impact on the future the pessimist
on the other hand sees negative events
as permanent as part of life and destiny
the optimist makes a mistake and busts
it off the pessimist makes a mistake and
considers that he or she is not really
good enough he or she is not competent
he or she is not likable popular or
successful and becomes depressed becomes
possessed by self-pity sees themselves
as a victim and feels like quitting the
second difference between the optimist
and the pessimist is that the optimist
sees difficulties as specific of a
pessimist sees them as pervasive this is
really important this means that when
things go wrong for the optimist he
looks at the event as an isolated
incident largely disconnected from other
things that are going on in his life he
deals with it and gets busy and puts it
behind him for example if something you
were counting on failed to materialize
and you interpret it to yourself as
being an unfortunate event but something
that happens in the course of life and
business you know
stuff happens you would be reacting like
an optimist
the pessimist on the other hand is
different the pessimist sees
disappointment as being pervasive ah
whoa me to him who setbacks are
indications of a problem or shortcomings
that pervades every area of his or her
life they have this what's the use
attitude the third difference between
optimist and pessimist is an optimist
see events as external while pessimist
interpret events as personal when things
go wrong the optimist will stand to see
the setback is resulting from external
factors over which one has little
control for example if the optimist is
caught in traffic instead of getting
angry or upset he will simply downgrade
the importance of the event by saying
something like oh well I guess that
person just had in a bad day or maybe he
or she's on a in a hurry to get to work
or something like that
the pessimist on the other hand has a
tendency to take everything personally
if the pessimist is cut off in traffic
he or she will react as though the other
driver has gotten up that smart morning
and driven through traffic and
deliberately acted to cut them off to
make them upset and angry the hallmark
of the fully mature fully functioning
self actualizing personality is the
ability to be objective and unemotional
when caught up in the inevitable storms
of daily life the superior person has
the ability to continue talking to
himself in a positive and optimistic way
keeping his mind calm and clear and
completely under control
the mature personality is more relaxed
and aware and capable of interpreting
events more realistically and less
emotionally than is the immature
personality as a result the mature
person exerts a far greater sense of
control and influence over his
environment and is far less likely to be
angry or upset or distracted as the
Buddhist
the mature person practises detachment
and though they're concerned about
things they don't get excited they just
stay calm
starting today we're off to think like
an optimist no matter what happens look
for the good in every situation look for
a lesson that you can learn when you
have a failure or setback you may not be
able to control events that you can
control the way you react to them and in
doing that to control your whole life
how do you really take a bad day and
restructure it so that you can actually
turn it into something valuable and so
I'm going to share with you the five PS
of turning a bad day into a valuable day
and even an epic day and I'm going to
dial right into the first one which is
perspective the perspective is a word
that seems very simple but I think it's
very powerful it's very easy to get
seduced into making something small a
lot larger than it is and perspective
simply reminds us to go to 50,000 feet
on a bad day and count our blessings
perspective simply reminds us that
things could be a lot worse perspective
on a bad day is simply understanding
that we live in a world where half the
world's population lives on less than
two dollars and fifty cents a day
perspective on a bad day is reminding
yourself that of that Persian proverb
which says I curse the fact I had no
shoes until I saw the man who had no
feet perspective is such a powerful word
here's a great question on a bad day to
bring on some perspective has anyone
died here so perspective something I
really want you to think about and on a
bad day it will actually allow you to
turn the lead into gold and really pivot
which brings me to the second P of
turning a bad day into a great day and
it's pivot and here's the question to
really help you pivot w toh
what's the opportunity here so you're
having a bad day maybe you had a fight
with someone maybe you lost the big sale
maybe someone cut you off in traffic and
then you didn't get your favorite
favorite lunch and then you missed
getting into SoulCycle class and then
you had a difficulty on the way home so
let's say that's happening you simply
run the WT o H question which will allow
you to pivot w toh what's the
opportunity here see there's great power
in a question and it allows your brain
to hunt for something good and so how do
you pivot you ask yourself what's the
opportunity here you have a fight with
someone let's say one of your family
members you say what's the opportunity
here well your brain then starts to look
for the opportunity which is I can learn
how to communicate better or this is an
opportunity for me to show forgiveness
and grow in my personal bravery this is
an opportunity for me to understand my
family member better it's a great and
powerful question which brings me to my
third P in turning a bad day into a
great day and it's really pharmacy the
third P is pharmacy and that's all about
moving when I have a difficult day
here's one of the first things I do I
will get on my mountain bike and I will
ride like a bat out of wherever through
the forest and that releases dopamine in
my brain which is the neurotransmitter
of inspiration and that releases
serotonin moving right on the bicycle it
releases serotonin which is the pleasure
neurotransmitter and it cuts down on my
cortisol which is the fear hormone so
just simply going for a mountain bike
ride or going for a swim or getting into
yoga class or something as simple as
going for a walk or maybe even doing
jumping jacks when no one's looking will
create a pharmacy of mastery within your
brain which will affect your psychology
your neurobiology and your interior life
which makes you just feel a lot better
you know that after a workout you all
we feel different than you did before
you went into the work and related to a
pharmacy of mastery is something that I
have counted on for years when I've had
good seasons when I've had challenging
seasons of my life massage I call it the
to massage protocol to massages every
single week it moves your lymph it moves
your blood which oxygenate your system
it reduces toxicity you feel a whole lot
better which brings me to the fourth P
in turning a bad day into a great day
pages you know I love journaling and for
hundreds and hundreds of years people
who have gone through difficulty people
who are experiencing calamity and chaos
open a journal turn to a fresh white
page and pour their pain or pour their
confusion pour their frustration out
onto that page it does something so
powerful it allows for a profound
release of what you're experiencing out
onto the written page here's the key if
you will repress and suppress your
feelings of anger of sadness of
disappointment all of those lower energy
feelings if you keep them inside they
not only build up toxicity and they
build up resentment with frustration but
those are the very things that lead to
inflammation that create this ease and
so what I'm sharing with you grit with
great love and respect is really very
potent pages the fourth for of turning a
bad day into a great day pull out your
journal and write what you're feeling
onto a fresh crisp written page which
brings me to my fifth and final P in the
five PS of turning a bad day into a
great day the planet and you're saying
Robin what are you talking about here
well nature nature is life's sweet
recovery method going for a walk in the
woods or walking on a beach and getting
next to the ocean or if you live near a
desert
getting out there if you're blessed to
live by the mountains you know what I'm
talking about but when you go out to
nature it grounds you when you connect
with the planet again nature what does
it do it gives you that recovery method
so you actually breathe in the fresh air
but it reminds you you are part of
something so much bigger than yourself
and maybe your bad day is taking you to
a better place
you know you for that old idea but life
doesn't really happen to you that life
really happens for you and there is this
incredible intelligence to life we don't
understand it look you and I are humans
we resist it but what if the thing you
see is bad is just your false belief
system judging it as bad we all know
this the things that we seem as bad over
time turned about to be blessings and so
everything is really happening - for you
for your best interest it's taking to
you to a better place it's making you
stronger it's teaching you great lessons
often we resist it but it all comes for
our good so those are the five P's to
take a bad day and really transmute it
into a great day definitely do these
five because these are all muscles and
like anything the more you practice the
stronger and more fluent you're going to
get and if you keep on practicing you're
going to get to a place where everyone
else is feeling oh I've gone through
this difficulty it's a bad day and
you're going to see this possibility and
you're going to be masterful and turning
the difficulty into opportunity hope
event of service I'll talk to you soon
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what did you think what did
you learn from this video that you're
going to apply immediately somehow to
your life or to your business leave it
down the comments below I'm really
excited to hear from you and we could
leave a comment within the first few
hours of this video going live you might
win one of our two elite private I also
want to give a quick shout out to Daniel
and Alexandra thank you guys so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and post in that awesome five star
review on Amazon I really really really
appreciate it I'm so glad the book kind
of impact on your life and thank you so
much for sharing and supporting thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love
[Music]
now my house is great I like my old
house by house its way I can do anything
good yeah yeah I can give any gold and
now you might also have the subjection
or this thought that goes something like
this well Leo okay positive thinking I
hear you it sounds nice but isn't
positive thinking actually dangerous I
mean I'm a realist
if then it is that better to be a
realist in life rather than to be this
starry-eyed optimist and approach
everything optimistically isn't realism
the best approach I mean what if you're
optimistic and then you're all that
optimism that you have all those goals
and dreams and the outcomes you set for
yourself all those just come crashing
down when it comes to kind of collides
with reality what if you're cheerful and
you're telling us not to be all happy
that someone close to you dies and then
you're not able to maintain that what
happens then Leo isn't that reckless
isn't that dangerous aren't you setting
yourself up for pain and the answer is
this you are setting up yourself for
pain if what you're doing is you're
setting these hard expectations and
you're very attached to the outcome but
it doesn't have to be that way right see
this is where discounters and Mayfair's
are positive thinking we'll get it wrong
if they'll say well positive thinking
that's going to set me up for failure
that's going to set up to disappointment
well the problem is that they're being
positive and they're telling yourself
well I'm positive on any the outcome to
be positive and if it's not positive
then everything's going to hell but the
true positive thinking is like be more
relaxed a more chill the outcome
matched you're a positive thinker you're
thinking positive about the situation
that doesn't mean that the situation
won't turn bad that doesn't mean that
you can foretell the future and you can
get everything that you want to happen
in your life to happen in the way that
you want it never going to happen on the
contrary it means that you're going to
have ups and downs you're going to have
things unexpectedly happen you might
have some sort of lofty ambition or goal
for your business and then it comes
crashing down and you know the market
comes and it it crashes and your
business crashes with it or maybe you
have some nice expectations and you're
thinking very positive about your
relationship and then your relationship
ends in a divorce that could happen so
I'm not saying you can necessarily
prevent that in all situations but the
idea here is that if you're a positive
thinker you remain positive and you're
not attached to it see if you're a
realist or a pessimist then actually
what you're doing is you're like like
okay if I'm thinking positive that I
needed to actually pan out I need it to
be positive all the time and of course
that's not going to work
that's a neurotic way of doing positive
thinking true positive thing you like
being cool and chill it's like you know
what if it happens good and if it
doesn't happen you know still good heads
I win tails I win that's what a true
positive attitude is about all right so
I'm going to wrap it up here this is
what cultivating a positive attitude
means it's really about acceptance you
have to accept what do you have to
accept one if accept the present moment
as it is completely inevitable number
two you have to accept that worry is
completely useless and of no value to
you number three you have to accept the
cheerfulness is the best strategy to go
through life with and you have now
stright to live up to that right I know
it's hard
this doesn't mean it's easy it's going
to be very hard but if you're like me
then you see the long-term potential
here I mean how awesome would it be to
develop yourself internally so that you
could have a true positive attitude
about life so that no matter what
happens to you you can remain cheerful
so that you're not worrying and you're
not feeling like you have to worry
because you know that the worries not
helping it and that you're in the
present moment and you accept them
as it is if you can achieve all those
things and you basically it accomplished
nirvana
you've got heaven on earth you can't not
like nothing can hurt you you're
untouchable so this is a very powerful
goal to set for yourself is to cultivate
this attitude over you know over the
month in the years as you're growing
yourself and you're doing other stuff
try to move your way and internally up
towards having a true positive attitude
about life one thing that I have found
like really really hard about optimism
is you can't expect to become an
optimistic person overnight it doesn't
happen it's probably taken me like five
years of constant practicing to become
an optimistic person or someone that can
see the bright side of things and when
I'm in a bad mood or something I tend to
go back to my old habits and think
really negatively but in general it gets
easier it's easier to I guess have a
better perspective on things as you
practice so for those of you guys
wondering why it's so hard to be
optimistic don't need to wonder it is
really really hard especially if it
doesn't come naturally but I know that
you can be an optimistic person if you
try so I'm going to be sharing some of
my tips that I have used to help me and
I believe everyone is born with sort of
a natural level of happiness and there
have been scientific research studies
that have been done but everyone comes
with a baseline of happiness and
whatever that is for you that is kind of
where you naturally will sit so if
you're born like someone that isn't
naturally happy you have a lot more work
to do and you need a little bit more
practice but there's nothing wrong with
you and if you're a born a super happy
person then you don't really need to try
very hard to be optimistic and you and
if you were born someone that you know
wasn't born super duper like
happy-go-lucky kind of person you may
look around and see these people always
being so cheerful and bubbly and wonder
how the hell did they do it well I
believe they may have been born with it
but you know
I don't know some is just science so I
guess well there's a view that has a
baseline level that isn't high you just
need to switch the way you think about
things and I think this is something
I've been noticing really really like
obviously lately like with any given
situation there's always multiple ways
to look at it like if you get into a car
accident
you can either feel like you know the
worst thing that happened today and if
you can also think this is the luckiest
day on my life because I'm still alive
after having a car accident
so a person it can either be super duper
negative to you or it can be like oh my
god I'm alive I better live my life
better so you can see how something so
tragic and terrible can have two sides
of the coin pretty easily like I can
imagine someone feeling both feelings
and I will you'll probably know someone
in your life that will experience both
of these feelings so I guess when you
look at any situation objectively it's
kind of a choice
it's your choice to decide what any
given situation means to you and that is
your decision to make and no one else
can force you to think like it's a
negative situation and no one else can
force you to think it's a positive
situation I guess becoming an optimistic
person means making that choice in your
life and then sticking to it and being
really aware of the thought going in
your head and how you think etc because
someone can get cancer and they can have
two different reactions one person what
may take it as you know if that has to
do everything that they wanted to do and
help people and one may see like a
victim and think like it's the worst
then why did this happen to me and then
spend the rest of their days mulling
over and being really grumpy it's your
choice
really and either I'm using really
extreme examples like accidents and
cancer but it's these extreme examples I
can really show you the glaring
difference between how people think an
even though you don't automatically
think optimistically
it doesn't mean you can't do it overtime
so I always catch myself doing things
like this if I catch myself thinking
negative I will stop breathe and then
try and rethink about the situation
again and then when you do that that
process becomes easier much like lifting
weights at first lifting you know heavy
weights would be like really hard but if
you've practiced every single day and
then just a lift a little bit more every
single day you will actually get really
good at it and I don't know why I always
use weights as an example but I don't
know the gym is just my go-to example
for things I have no idea why but yeah
so whatever situation you're in right
now and you're feeling really down about
it I want you to sit down with a piece
of paper or even in your mind it really
depends on which way is easier for you
and to think of all the different ways
someone can think of that situation you
don't have to put yourself in that
situation personally yet pretend you
have five different friends how would
each of them think about this situation
and then you can list out all the ways I
could think about it differently
and I will really open your eyes on the
amount of ways that you can think about
it yourself and then you can choose the
one that will help you the best because
at the end of the day whatever you think
about this situation will determine what
your future can be someone that thinks
positively of a really bad situation can
end up being you know the person that
helps many other people in the same
situation through sharing their story
opening a charity or doing volunteer
work and then the other very same person
can affect their future by playing the
victim and then spending the rest of
their time making all their friends
miserable by dragging them into there
that's sad story